[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast if
you would just take a quick second and
please hit the Subscribe button it means
so much to me and the team for all the
hard work we put into these episodes to
get the guests that we do and the more
subscribers we have the better job we
can do for you so please hit subscribe
today on the show
I mean this is a big deal David Wilcox
is on the phone he has not done an
interview in two years he might
recognize him from Ancient Aliens he's a
filmmaker he's a professional lecturer
he's an author and he's a researcher of
ancient civilizations he's been in the
UFO community and talking about it and
exposing it for so long all of this
started for him in the late 90s we talk
about deep State we talk about UFOs we
talk about ancient civilizations we talk
about cataclysms we talk about where
things are going on this planet
Consciousness and what will help us just
get to the next level and also
new secret technologies that are
available I have a feeling that the
community that watches this will love it
please let me know what you think in the
comments I love reading those I love
hearing if you have any stories and just
what you think where do you think the
plan is going let me know all great
athletes have one thing in common they
take care of their bodies it's something
that we do from a young age whether we
work out the food that we eat how we
prepare our mind this is all part of
becoming a great athlete and one thing
that I do every single morning is I
drink ag1 I do it before I have coffee I
do it before I eat any food I really
feel like for me it's helped my gut
health it's made my stomach just feel
like less bloated and more calm
throughout the day it handles all food
so much better I'm putting like 75 high
quality ingredients into my body first
thing in the day which makes a huge
difference even if I'm traveling I use
the travel packs I was in Europe for six
weeks every single day I put ag1 into my
body so if a comprehensive solution is
what you need from your supplement
routine then ag-1 is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase go to drinkag1.com pretty
intense that's drink ag1.com pretty
intense check it out yeah
I've been following you for so long I
have listened to so many different you
know movies and interviews and all kinds
of various different things and the last
time I listened to something that you
put out there was it was when covet had
just happened
I'm sitting there on the beach in Malibu
and I watched the live stream it was
like you did like maybe over three hour
live stream kind of video and it was
talking about yeah right at the
beginning and it was you were talking
about all the things that you know
you've been talking about that are
coming to fruition and what is coming
down the pipeline and one of the things
was about like a sort of a technical
shutdown or computers and services will
just go down and so from that point on
anytime like Twitter or Instagram or
something shut down I thought this is it
it's coming the whole shutdown's coming
um but that was the last time sorry
about that that no it will maybe it'll
happen someday I mean I can't imagine
what happened I think I mean it probably
will so that was the last time I heard
much from you so what the heck have you
been doing
life has gotten really interesting with
uh David grush testifying in Congress
that UFOs are real
and that he was part of this uh group in
the National reconnaissance office where
he came across information that there
are multiple
crashed UFOs
and unfortunately a lot of people in The
Patriot Community have who poohed this
whole thing and been rather uh
dismissive of it
and said well it's just a distraction
from other things that are going on but
I would say that
the realization of UFOs as something
that's not science fiction but is
truthful
will have enormous ramifications
on every single aspect of our society
the way we live
and
probably one of the biggest ones is the
sudden Quantum Leap in technology that
we will have once the things that have
been classified are no longer kept
classified I'm working in an aerospace
company
and this is the sm-39 razor this is our
own design it's a proprietary unique jet
airplane design
and this is going to be the fastest air
aircraft ever made it's going to go Mach
4 and what we're doing here is we are
revolutionizing several different types
of of technology I decided to go beyond
just being somebody who talks about UFOs
and let's put my money where my mouth is
and build something I've worked for many
years obviously as your listeners might
know I've done Ancient Aliens I'm in
over 100 episodes of the show and they
run it pretty much all day Friday and
Saturday on History Channel so I know
yeah right as a French and aliens
the the you know the the three words you
hear the most are are you David I mean
I'm cool about that I you know when when
people want to meet me I I'm I'm usually
really nice I've almost never been a
jerk and if there's a few times I was
I'm sorry you know sometimes I'm just
overwhelmed if it's an event I've done
this Ancient Aliens thing and and it
made me into a very significant public
figure just by virtue of the fact that I
don't know any other show that's getting
that much replay uh where it's on
television all the time there is a deep
Fascination even I can see this within
my show when there's an episode and when
there's a guest that's talking about
UFOs and aliens and even spirituality
and just more esoteric topics people
really really want to know about it well
it's something that affects us in such a
dramatic fashion uh once you understand
that you're not alone in the universe
all these new Avenues of exploration
open up uh we find out that these
pyramids
would be a pretty ideal thing to do
if you came to a planet from somewhere
else and you didn't want to tell a big
trailer behind you when you got there
you know
you want to build something when you got
there and you want to build something
that's going to last and if you have
anti-gravity you could direct the same
gravitational
reduction that you're putting on your
own craft that causes it to levitate you
could do it on blocks of stone right
and it appears that they also have some
method that allows them to make stone
pliable at room temperature
so it's essentially like a liquid and
you can you know sculpt it and then when
you turn the beam off it hardens and you
got that's what I think is going on
sucks table man in Peru that's one of
the things that's probably the biggest
ancient alien Blockbuster of all you
know you go out to Peru it's a 13 000
foot altitude you can barely breathe up
there and they've got this wall that's
made out of these rocks that have eight
foot wide cracks
that are just pushed together as if they
were all mushed together like balloons
yeah and the crack between the Rocks is
so thin you can't put a credit card in
there you can't even fit a hair in there
there's no mortar it's all just been
kind of like fitted that way and so
to try to even suggest that somebody
would have the time or the patience to
carve that
is ridiculous it had to have been that
the stones were levitating and just kind
of mushed together because they were
soft
so then you got to say to yourself okay
wow
what does that mean about everything
that we thought we knew and if you don't
think far enough back into history then
you might miss a lot of big Clues you
know you might miss the fact that
the Japanese had a very large budget and
they wanted to build a Great Pyramid
mock-up at one-fifth the size 500
percent smaller with the very best laser
controlled technology the cranes you
name it
they could not get it to work
so the Great Pyramid is something that
is completely Beyond any capacity that
we could have used with technology today
and
I think what's even more outrageous is
when it was first constructed it had
mirror polished White Stone on the
outside right it looked like a marble
gleaming perfect alien structure in the
desert and it was only actually some
earthquakes that occurred in the early
uh late 1300s early 1400s that knocked
them down
and then they went and were used for
mocks and Cairo what about the tops
there was a piece of gold up there and
and I think that got stolen by somebody
who do you think it was I mean Egypt has
been through a few different rounds and
there was a a high point in their
civilization called Zep Tepe which was
the first time how far back do the
rounds go when you say rounds because
you don't just mean like the Romans and
Egyptians you mean like you mean General
civilizations in history so typically
they call it uh the Pyramid of key Ops
and then the one next to it is
supposedly the Pyramid of kefiren and
the third smaller one is the Pyramid of
menkare now these are Egyptian pharaohs
in a more recent Dynasty
uh and key Ops the the the the
connection that key Ops built the tomb
is extremely weak and Zechariah sitchin
did an amazing breakdown on that where
uh sir Flinders Petri was the guy who
supposedly found these Quarry marks
inside the king's chamber uh that said
that kiops built the Pyramid and this
was when he'd run out of money he was
going to have to go back to England
empty-handed uh you know everybody was
really depressed because they were
hoping to find inscriptions in the
king's chamber they'd opened it up for
the first time nobody been in there
before they didn't find anything
so all of a sudden
on the last day in this little tunnel
that he dug himself he finds these cave
markings on the wall that were at just
the right angle for him to have done it
with his own hand with red paint
and it had all the mistakes consistent
with E.W Wallace budge's classic book on
Egyptian hieroglyphics for that time so
all the mistakes that budge made in the
classic hieroglyphic book is he was
copying out of that and trying to say
key Ops built the Pyramid he made the
same mistakes huh whoops that's the only
piece of evidence they've ever gotten
that says kiops built the Pyramid oh wow
so it's and it's it's so easily debunked
and sitchin did an amazing job on that
it's in his book Genesis for visited
so
when we get to what really was happening
if you talk to uh
somebody like Robert boval of course
you've probably heard of the Giza
alignment and this is where the Pyramid
of the three pyramids we were just
talking about
are the same in the size and position as
the three stars in the belt of the
constellation Orion right and then you
have other parts of the constellation
Orion that also add up to where the
pyramids are located and as an even
greater bonus
the location of the Nile River precisely
corresponds to the Milky Way galaxy so
this appears to be intentional but
what's really cool about it is that
because of the earth wobbling over 26
000 years in this so-called precession
of the equinoxes
in that uh movement you have one degree
every 72 years where the stars drift by
one degree every 72 years if you look at
it on the equinox
which is why if you try to align any
type of pyramid or stone monument to the
Stars you're going to be screwed after
72 years it's already off by one degree
people are mad at you they're going to
chop your head off
if they were not very kind but but then
it dates it based on the degree it gives
you a time window where you can say wait
a minute when is the when does the Nile
River Line up with the Milky Way right
when does all that stuff happen and it
happens in 10 450 BC
which is not supposed to be part of the
conventional dating era and if we want
to go Ancient Aliens for a while we've
now got this other area in Turkey
which is Gobekli Tepe yeah and they
found multiple Stone circles that they
know
couldn't have been buried underground
until 13 000 years ago so whatever the
civilization was in Turkey predated 13
000 BC
so we're gonna have to go through this
whole process as a society where the the
typical
delineation of that nothing before 5 000
years ago right other than cavemen right
right that's not the way it is I mean it
just bothers me when people are are
really think there's no proof that
there's obviously been other technology
I don't know what what it was was it
aliens war with some more sophisticated
race have we had
resets
based on being wiped out or some other
sort of technology that would reset us I
don't necessarily know I have my own
feelings but the proof is everywhere all
you have to do is just walk around any
European city walk around Egypt for a
second look at a pyramid look at how
gigantic it is look go to Machu Picchu
and say how did they get those stones up
there why are they so perfectly melted
together like like the proof is
everywhere and I just don't understand
why people wonder so much so how can we
be so blind how can how is that possible
was our Consciousness not at a point
that we could accept any more truth than
whatever we were given or is this been
sort of like a reboot from you know
Baseline civilization kind of a human
and we've had to we've had to just
evolve to the point where we can
understand it
well we have to remember that we have
animal bodies and so all of the
different types of uh plants animals
birds and fish that we see on Earth
are about 99 the same as us in our DNA
DNA variations and this one things I
talk about in my new books the DNA
variations are very very minute
and so we like to think of ourselves as
something entirely different than
animals and in fact
if you study like behaviorism in
psychology and especially body language
you can learn how people tell you things
that they don't want you to know by how
they hold their bodies and by how they
use their face
and I've learned those things a long
time ago I read a book on body language
in seventh grade it was uh Body Language
by Dr Julius fast
so I was amazed at how
many of these things are happening that
people don't understand and
like for example the way that people
cross their legs when they're sitting
together was one of the things he talks
about and how you'll cross your leg and
point your foot towards the person who
you are in favor of
and uh he was also talking about signs
that women do subconsciously when
they're trying to drive a man away
and it's it's these kind of Crossing
like if they cross their hands like this
or if they cross their legs of course it
had
a lot of the stuff that is commonly seen
about you know pupillary dilation he
talks about that
so the the point is once you really
understand psychology
we have a lot more in common with the
animal kingdom than we want to believe
and this includes our desire to go along
with a pack Consciousness a group
consciousness
and what we've seen time and time again
especially in the recent past is it's
very difficult
for people to truly
individuate to have their own
their own perspective that is not
something they want to feel confident
that they're going along with what
everybody else says but they've actually
been able to make up their own mind and
make their own decision
so it's an interesting thing because
Ancient Aliens is now a very popular
show you know they were spending north
of 350k per episode
very good budget very nice production
value and it's so much of it it's out
there all the time and so it's kind of
just become mainstream now but we're
still not really adding that to
textbooks or any type of normal
discourse like what you and I are having
now it's still considered kind of like
this fun thing to check into before you
sort of take it off like a suit and put
it in the closet and go back to reality
no obviously there are egos involved but
then there's probably something else and
it's the something else that I'm really
curious about the more nefarious
sort of reasons within you know
government or certain global companies
that are running the world
um media Outlets the few that really run
all of the media you know what is the
goal there Central Banking I I mean the
Commodities of the world like why would
we be better off not knowing we would be
better off not knowing for them because
they'd keep making money the way that
they're making money and it's assumed
that as soon as there's new technology
there's new there's new wealth and new
control in the world and it's not them
well when Danica Patrick asks you about
the Deep State on YouTube what do you
say everything yeah let me tell you all
about the entrails and how they like to
wear it around their neck it's awesome
I'm joking of course but uh let's just
joke about everything let's talk about
all the reptilians in power and things
like well you wanted to go there I mean
it's like okay wow a woman wants to talk
about that that's kind of amazing I mean
most people shy away from this how are
we ever going to heal if you don't face
the shadow right I mean each one of us
has character deficits that are based
upon where we stand in the universe as
opposed to the overall design of what
things are and how it works here for me
the the UFO question is always a
philosophical one and it gets into are
there philosophical teachings that we
can put into practice in our own lives
that will actually make us Kinder and
more compassionate and more forgiving
and patient people
while at the same time creating
an evolution into some type of metahuman
uh and apparently the reason why this is
happening is that all of the research
I've done over the years to me it's not
even really about extraterrestrials it's
about what is the universe
what is the universe what the heck are
we living in and is it real a lot of the
concepts of the Matrix do apply
to uh
scientific understanding of the universe
we've now found out
through the work of a physicist named Dr
Nima arkani Hamed
that you can build the entire universe
off of a small
minute geometric pattern
and that from that minute pattern which
looks like the Star of David in three
dimensions is basically the Hebrew Star
of David you take the Hebrew Star of
David
and you can create the whole universe of
space and time
and then what the physics actually says
is that it's as if we're like like 30
frames per second in a can right there's
a film and when the film runs through
the projector there's 30 frames per
second it looks like I'm talking to you
but there's just one frame where I'm
like this and one frame where I'm like
this and so the whole universe is
blinking on and off like that in space
and in time one of the first times I
tried an edible and my I was trying to
convey this information while laughing
and saying I'm losing frames and I was
like I'm losing frames like I like link
and all of a sudden I'm here now I'm
like I'm losing my mind like I'm losing
frames I'm missing I'm missing missing
information did you have a smear in Your
Vision like when you wave your hand
um probably I don't know yeah that's
called Trails I mean that's a yeah if
you take enough of an edible and you
know you'll get that psychedelic quality
and the Psychedelic experience can
include you know the brain is is
beleaguered by whatever substance you
took and the frame rate goes down you
know so yeah you'll actually experience
that frame dropping yeah but that is our
nature of reality it everything is just
frames right like it's not we are not a
continuous motion it's frames is this is
this how you see it now we're getting
into really
hair splitting but yeah so check this
out
there is a reality
that we wake up into when we wake up
into our body in the morning
and then when you go to sleep you're
putting your body down it's like you
take off a pair of shoes and you leave
by the side of the bed
when you're not in your body you're
having all these other experiences in
these other realities but while you are
in this body
you are bound by the rules within this
illusion
so the illusion
will persist we do have space and time
that does exist in this reality however
if you really get into the esoteric
physics of this and the science of it
the universe itself is the logos and the
logos is what the Bible says is the term
word
so uh in in John in the Book of John you
have in the beginning there was the word
and the Word was God and the Word was
with God it's so it's like wait a minute
the Word was God and the Word was with
God so
the esoteric explanation of that is that
we have a conscious Universe which is a
one infinite creator
and then we also have a conscious Galaxy
and so we have to stop looking at stars
as just being these blobs and they're
actually
far more intelligent super beings than
we are
and they give hosts to planets that have
intelligent life like us
and there is actually a universal law of
uh
honoring each other's free will
and if you violate other people's Free
Will you're going to get karma so
for me the basic thing we all have to
learn is that if you love each other
you're actually going to not suffer
you're not going to get that car crash
you're not going to get that bankruptcy
or that sudden betrayal and instead
things will start to work out for you so
it does appear again if you get to like
Tibetan Buddhism and this kind of stuff
that there is a way in which you can
meditate as if you become empty
awareness that's the two key words in
tibetan thing is empty awareness so you
you project yourself into the vision of
what you're seeing so like in Tibet they
would be in the mountains they look out
at a mountain view
they imagine that they are the mountains
they are the sky they are the clouds and
then they say that all of that once they
feel like they have become everything
around them then they say all of that
emanated from the empty awareness and if
you meditate on that and you don't have
any angry thoughts for 13 years
then you get to have a rainbow body
activation
and you basically turn into a superhero
and your body turns into into light the
rainbow body I feel like I've seen it
I've seen images they you you're sort of
like your your human body
shrinks because well we're not really
we're just We're Just Energy anyway
normally you would expect when somebody
dies they leave behind an intact
skeleton and the skeleton is life-size
you don't expect it to be smaller and
you don't expect it to shrink so there's
something very strange happening with
with the rainbow body phenomenon uh
there was a Catholic priest named father
Francis tiso he was sponsored by The
Institute of noetic Sciences ions or
ions he went over to Tibet and there was
a a llama who was going to attain
rainbow body
and father TSO was there and he observed
this and they've also done this with uh
military observers they've they've
scientifically documented that this is a
reality that what you have an old man
and they wrap him up when so so he knows
when he's going to die first of all he
just closes his eyes and he kind of
leans back and his body is gone wow
there's a protocol at that point where
you wrap him up in these very colorful
silk uh Fabrics
but after he starts sitting there very
strange things begin to happen
the body's interred okay it's wrapped up
in the fabric
people have looked through the fabric
and what they find out is that the face
reverses its aging
it looks like a young face first all the
lines seem to go away which is like yeah
I love that
little rainbow just a little Rainbow
body yeah and they begin seeing rainbows
around the body they begin seeing
rainbows around the building they hear
weird melodic music coming through
and then the the Llama starts appearing
to people in as like a ghost
so this and then after the after the
course of seven days
in in one of there's a couple different
varieties of how this happens but in one
of the varieties the body has now
shranked down to a little figurine about
this big right and it's it's basically
Ash
and it's in the shape of a human body
roughly but very roughly
and what they do and there's lots of
these displays around Tibet is they
actually Dress It Up in little clothes
and put it in a little altar has the the
the person left it behind you know there
was a a leak from tulku ergyan
rinkpochet in a book called rainbow
painting
where he said that you have to do it for
13 years you have to meditate on empty
awareness for 13 years and not have
negative thoughts
and you know I mean in an American
society modern society we're in now how
are you going to get even one day I got
angry before we ever got on camera you
know working with my gear now I gotta
talk to him I mean that that actually I
mean it's funny and true and indicative
of the culture that we live in which is
so distracting yeah we're we're in a
culture that is competing for attention
and money you know everything is trying
to listen to you it's it's so bizarre
now like I I said you know what I don't
want to look up Danica Patrick because
if I do I'm probably going to have
advertisements that show you to me all
the time
I don't want to like experience you that
way you know
so
um because it's so there's a there's a
lack of privacy and a lot of people just
sort of feel comfortable with that or
they did
up until it starts to really affect your
life in a negative way and so you you
did ask me about the Deep State and that
kind of thing
um but what I'm saying is before we get
to that just to cap off this
philosophical discussion the Tibetan
research is conclusive you have Padma
sambhava was the so-called second Buddha
and he had some 30 plus disciples who
all were able to levitate up into the
air with him as a result of following
these practices so we know
that when you strive to live as lovingly
and as compassionately as possible with
a disciplined personality
that there are
superhuman things that start to happen
to you they call them City powers
s-i-d-h-i
and the cities are a very interesting
thing that is very consistent as people
go through this process and the pyramid
has the king's chamber in it with the
sarcophagus and that appears to be a
technology that can create the rainbow
body activation oh really sarcophagus
for sure or was it or did it hold the
Ark of the Covenant like I mean there's
a lot of a lot of thoughts about that
I wrote in my third book I guess the
Ascension Mysteries that the the
measurements of the Ark of the Covenant
as described in the Old Testament
are precisely identical to the king's
chamber sarcophagus right now that's
weird because the sarcophagus hadn't
been discovered yet officially until
Khalifa Mamoon bored a hole through and
got in there in the early A.D okay so
what the heck are we doing with the Old
Testament having the same measurements
well there was a secret entrance that
the priests were using to get up into
that chamber
and so that that those measurements were
the result of secret knowledge in the
Old Testament but
when we look at the pyramid structure
we've had modern experience with
building them in Russia
and we see that they have incredible
benefits to People's Health
most striking study was well there's
lots of things you could take carcinogen
inject carcinogen into mice
you have a control group that you put
them outside the pyramid
and let's say 70 percent of them die of
cancer only seven percent of them in the
pyramid will die of cancer oh wow I'm
sure you've been in it many times
well I'm in a log home here and the
reason why I got one is that I wanted to
have that Pyramid Power because you
don't want any metal so my house is
alive it's just these thick beefy logs
you don't want metal
not if you're gonna have a pyramid no
because it'll absorb these unique Fields
it's one of the ways you could talk
about is it's the transverse wave
there's this uh Natural Energy that the
pyramid is built to harness okay yeah
yeah I have you heard of um like bio bio
bio geometry and how there's sort of
like a grain like with certain patterns
there will be materials there's like a
green a negative green and a positive
green and one is kind of detrimental to
your health and one is positive I've
done a lot of work on matter and what is
matter and it really does appear that
our our solution comes in sacred
geometry
and that we're going to learn that uh
it's not really a particle as much as
it's sort of like
standing wave
and what that means is it's a wave that
rotates it within itself and holds its
position
so it's kind of just standing there in
space but it's got motion inside of it
and so we're not
sacred geometry is is such a huge
subject uh we can get into the fact that
there was a professor Henry markram
who conducted the most advanced uh
analysis of the brain and concluded that
the brain is processing thought in these
three-dimensional patterns
the cubes tetrahedrons
uh octahedrons are the three that he
specifically found in his paper
and so when we see that the the
mechanism of our Consciousness the
actual mapping out of thought
creates these sacred geometric patterns
which are the same patterns that exist
in matter this explains why somebody
like Padma sambhava was able to go
around and push his hand into the Rock
and leave a handprint or a footprint and
that's a that's a classic miracle that
these Tibetan llamas would would create
once they had achieved a certain level
of the rainbow body activation
they were able to match the frequency
and match the in the same way as I was
saying with sake woman where they had
some type of technology that could melt
those stones together just mush them
together like that when you get to this
level of Consciousness like Padma
sambhava had you you can change the
matter phase of the Stone
and and and work with it as if it was a
liquid he could he could wave his hand
and create a pattern like a raised
relief pattern on Rock like he just
etched it all out over the course of
hours and it would just appear in Solid
Rock
and there's several of these all over
the place in Bhutan Tibet Nepal India
you know that people went around doing
this and they built shrines there so you
go there and you throw money in there
and you see the footprint of the
handprint it's all over the place
there's there's dozens of them actually
the nature of this reality is just so
much more than what we understand what
do you think the next step of
understanding more of the nature of this
reality will be that it'll take us to
the next phase of humanity the next
technical level Revolution Evolution
what do you think that will be well it's
happening
um with the Aerospace company that I'm
working on here
I have a guy who
my own insiders I I've spent many years
developing credibility online uh as this
personality who talks about UFOs I had a
website in 1999 I really didn't do
anything else
um wasn't watching television I mean
most of the television shows I'm in I've
never seen I've only probably watched
seven percent of my own shows because I
just
I don't have time I mean I would
probably like to watch them but I just
don't have time so
uh I just haven't really seen much
television but what I have done is I'm
like an information junkie I'm addicted
to information
and I've been cramming all this stuff
into my head so
I had real insiders start to contact me
after I went public with a website in
1999. the first really genuine insiders
I met who who well no
no it was as early as 2002 that I began
meeting some really high octane insiders
I had a guy who we can now say his name
his name was Bruce perrett he was a
physicist and he showed up when I was
living in Louisville Kentucky to live in
our little Community I was with l l
research these are the people that did
the law of one
law of one is my own spiritual Source
text I find it
you know a very uniquely beneficial uh
source of information
so I actually went out and lived with
them for two years uh in 2002 through
2004. and so Bruce showed up while we
were there
and he had worked on the Montauk project
and he made me come up with a cover
story so the cover story was that I met
him at a Denny's in Albany
but the truth was he was living with us
and so I got to talk to him extensively
and you find out that wait a minute
there's this whole strange thing going
on
and I mean if if if all you can wrap
your head around and I know I'm not I'm
speaking the colloquial you Danica not
to you personally
if all you is the colloquial you can
wrap your head around is I wonder if
Roswell really happened
right
you don't understand what's going on
here there's been this 80-year
technological exploitation process
underway
and we have
if you want to call it this you could
say there's Americans
in something like 63 different locations
around the Galaxy
we out we already have bases in our
galaxy we already have working
spaceships we have facilities on the
moon we have facilities on Mars Other
satellites in our solar system and
what's even more outrageous than that of
course it's all been kept secret
is that we are in that in those programs
in those classified programs
we are actively in contact with
extraterrestrials
and they interact with us much like the
Cantina scene in Star Wars right like a
galactic the Galactic Federation yeah
that's real and uh I mean you've done a
lot of stuff with Corey Goode and I'm
sure that you know from your own
experiences and
intuition and visions and as well as
Corey's and probably others there's a
lot of corroboration oh yeah I mean what
we did with Cosmic disclosure
was to talk about something that
I believe actually happened to me as
well at the time that we were doing the
show I hadn't really put it all together
yet but
it does appear that if you if you are
picked up by a UFO
as an abduction experience that
you could be taken away for a
significantly long time
maybe even years and then not remember
anything when they bring you back
because they can splice you back in to
the moment that you left timeline that's
one of the really odd aspects of this of
this whole new technology
is that we are going to have to deal
with the paradoxes of time travel right
because it's not the same it's not a
linear thing in all of the universe and
time space reality is just here and from
what I understand there's interesting
stuff about this technology that you
guys are working on with the spaceship
program that includes sort of being able
to break that sort of
um mechanism that creates this reality
very much so uh the you know if you're
looking at an extraterrestrial spaceship
you obviously have solved the energy
crisis because they have enough fuel to
get here and not run out of gas right
right that's the first thing that comes
to mind is like you get there but you
can't get back you know so there's got
to be some kind of uh endless renewable
energy source that is never ending and
it's it's definitely real we're living
in this reality that is
underwritten by these extraterrestrials
they're not just here uh you know to
hang out they're actually paying
attention to us they're essentially what
we could think of as Angelic beings
and there are also some very bad ones
so we have
uh you go back to disclosure project
2001 Dr Stephen Greer
was at the national Press Club in
Washington DC and he brought forward at
that time on May 10 2001 or May 9th is
the one that he I went to the one on May
10th it's on May 9 2001 they had 39
Witnesses come forward in the National
Press Club
and it got a lot of attention at the
time it was quickly overshadowed by 9 11
but for its time it was a very
significant thing and I was there on the
May 10th event because I'd been on the
Art Bell show and I got in as a VIP
so I got to speak to these Insiders and
it was very amazing because we had
members of Congress in the audience and
everybody was doing standing ovations
as these guys are talking about things
like seeing architecture on the moon
you know and talking about retrieving uh
UFO occupants who are alive and having
this Sergeant Clifford Stone described
having this telepathic experience
of melding Minds with the being that was
in the ship yeah he didn't break down on
May 9th but he broke down crying on
stage on May 10th and he had to walk off
the stage in the corner and cry and I
mean
the audience was just galvanized people
are ready for this information that
there was a a colonel who was read into
this much more secret level of the
universe than he was he was part of this
crash retrieval team but they kind of
kept him ignorant
he was shown a three inch thick binder
that described 57 different varieties of
extraterrestrials that are visiting
Earth right now
and
they mostly they predominantly look
human so they have eyes nose mouth ears
you know a lot of them are going to have
bigger eyes a lot of them might not have
hair but they're not as different
looking as you would think are they
walking amongst by visiting is it
something where they can somewhat blend
in or are they visiting more ship wise
and I've had various insiders who seem
to be aware of this the The Interchange
program as far as I know there's only
ever maybe 10 or 20 000 of these humans
on Earth at any one time it might be
upwards of a hundred thousand I'm not
really sure I know that they're all
monitored very closely I probably know a
few
well one of the things I was told I'm
going to release this now I've never
said this before but
uh Jacob one of my insiders told me that
the body scanners at the airport
can also read for an unusual physiology
and that they're tracking immigration
and if somebody shows up here who
doesn't belong
they have that and then they have some
other things I won't go into where
they're going to find you you know if
you have different organs in your body
or something like that they're gonna
you can't just really blend in you know
so
all that stuff is very tightly monitored
and we're not in any danger it's all
been based on treaties and whatnot and
like Galactic Federation treaties
treaties with us us with
extraterrestrials with the Federation
that are immense yeah okay you could
argue about the Constitutional validity
of those considering they were made with
covert military organizations you know
uh but they do exist they're not
something that we got to hear about or
vote on but they do exist there are
agreements in place so Sergeant Stone
said there was 57 varieties
and in my new in my new books the
Michael prophecy books this is book six
now I've got a whole thing at the
beginning about this uh we have
what appears to be uh six that are bad
and then 51 that are good and that
appears to be where this is coming from
so the six that are bad
we have a fairly good amount of
information on those guys they they're
centered in the constellation Orion so a
lot of times they're called the orions
so there was like a thing in Italy the
Friendship case in Italy is a human ET
contact case
and they said yeah you know they the bad
guys are in Orion the law of one says
the bad guys are in Orion so everybody
seems to say the bad guys are in Orion
yet there's so many cons so many things
that are aligned with Orion as if it's
very significant the the way that that
constellation is built those are very
nearby stars and because they're all
clustered like that it creates a kind of
energetic cone for the Earth
so we have that in place and that would
be why the negative would want to go
there they want to go wherever the
action is if there's high energy High
Juice they want to be there so they're
going to move in on that land and try to
set up their own trailer park in there
and that's what they did so the star Rye
gel which is the bottom right there's
just it's it's a whole reptilian
infested solar system and um
these reptilians look human-like
but they are extremely frightening in
appearance and we've had lots of
kind of depictions of them in our
popular Mythos the most reliable
information that I've gotten on on the
way they look is it's not exactly like
the human face it kind of this part of
the face does punch forward a little bit
like this so the mouth kind of comes out
almost like Planet of the Apes that's
sort of they do have this kind of
protruding face like this but when they
open up that mouth it's it's it's
hideous sharp teeth and they are they
have vertical slip pupils their eyes
will either be like yellow or orange or
red so they're scary looking why did why
is there so much conspiracy around
reptilians being here being shapeshifter
reptilians well I don't believe in the
shapeshifter reptilian part except as so
to say that when people practice black
magic they have hallucinations
and I believe that there's some type of
conduit in which hallucinations well in
which entities from the lower astral
plane present themselves in
hallucinations and I think that when
people have seen a shape-shifting event
on someone's face
it's not that the flesh moved it's this
kind of hallucinatory overlay if
somebody is uh wittingly or unwittingly
collaborating with these types of
creatures
they're matching the energy of that
entity when we talk about spiritual
reality in general one of the things I
just learned in a recent briefing is
that uh this physical reality of space
and time this illusion uh is very
attractive to those in the spiritual
realm both the negative and the positive
everybody wants to be here you know it's
it gets boring in the spiritual reality
when you don't have a body and you don't
have any continuous experience and you
don't really have to worry about
anything because you know what's going
to happen in the future and it's all
kind of all laid out for you you know
there's no game anymore there's no
there's no winning and losing you know
you're you're in competitive Sports I
mean there's not there's no competition
anymore so David we totally sign up for
this we did every tough time we go if we
signed I signed up for this that's right
and I signed up for the toughest tougher
job I signed up for a tough one it's
it's really tough to be a public figure
and it's really tough to be seen by lots
of people and I get that I mean you know
are you David are the three words I hear
the most as I said so
uh when we get to the intrinsic truth of
higher consciousness
there are laws in the universe where if
you have positive thoughts
positive beings can strengthen those
thoughts and if you have negative
thoughts negative beings can strengthen
those thoughts in our galaxy there's a
further rule that gets us in even more
trouble which is the permeability of
dimensions
and that means that our galaxy has a law
in place
that allows angels to show up in the
room and meet you in person
but by virtue of how the universe works
on a principle of balance it also means
that demons can manifest that only
occurs in the context of of a human
offering if you will and most people
never do anything that's sick and crazy
so that you know Aleister Crowley if you
go back and you look at his his work
well he he was in touch with a being
called Lam
Lam and if you look that up it's a gray
okay what I got in a briefing in 2021
was that Lam taught Aleister Crowley
how to properly do black magic in order
to
allow demonic lower astral beings to
manifest in the room and then they
Channel through one of the people in the
room and also you'll get very strange
disturbing things like people
shape-shifting they might appear to look
like animals for a while all kinds of
crazy things can happen in these in
these ceremonies
and thank God I never was dragged in any
of this in in my Waking Life
uh but yeah there there does appear to
be
you know like this is the big secret why
are people doing all this crazy stuff
with children and sacrifice and and
blood and the answer is because it
creates results
you see something
oh you see something very dramatic power
very scary you hear it you see it you
smell it it's a being that shows up in
the room so is there power that they
generate from it do they are they given
yeah it talks to you and it asks you
what you want you know and so it's
basically like Mephistopheles and Faust
and it says how can I help you you know
what can I do to to to to satisfy your
wishes and it's but it also is actually
it says it wants your soul yep selling
yourself like who would be stupid enough
to play around with this stuff but
apparently people are doing people why
does it seem like so much there's so
much more satanic symbolism going on
right now especially when you look at
music industry and things like that I
mean there it's not hidden in in the
slightest they're red all over their
bodies blood everywhere
Satan horns like I mean it's it's like
very apparent
well
okay we gotta go back to Winston
Churchill and his quote was Satan's
greatest trick is convincing Humanity
that he does not exist I have found out
that in addition to the existence of
Good and Evil extraterrestrials that
it's considered an acknowledged fact in
these classified military programs
that universal law permits
entities to materialize in these
ceremonies if you do them properly
and uh so if you are that sick
you can get this to work and then
there is an interchange with this entity
and so once they see one of these they
make a sculpture out of it and that's
the gargoyle so if you look at a
building and it has these strange demons
on the outside
that's because those beings showed up in
there
and once that being starts to establish
its presence once you see it if you see
the Gargoyles you walk into the building
you look up at it you're making a
connection to that kind oh yeah totally
you know so they say that the Gargoyles
are the Protectors of the building well
that they're invoking inside the
building who will go after you if you
try to shut down the operation
it's this is real stuff I mean it's sad
that you know because it's so upsetting
to people to think about this but what
these demons or these entities want more
than anything they call them demonics in
the in the military Pro projects what
the demonics want is to
have the Earth for themselves they want
this to become a place where they are
allowed to be here where they can be in
physical form because right now
universal law doesn't allow that to
happen except in these weird evil
ceremonies if if enough of us got
excited about demons and said yeah you
know what I want to see one I want to
see one
how can we make that happen you know
then
they could start to do public
manifestations like they were doing back
in Rome where you sacrifice a bunch of
people at once they have a big arch and
then this entity pops up in the arch
like you're watching TV this thing just
pops up like whoa what the hell is that
it's green and it's got horns what the
hell you know well that's what was
happening wow well I um I interviewed uh
Elizabeth April I don't know if you've
heard of her she speaks about the
Galactic Federation and various
different things and she tells a story
that
um that the back you know many many you
know ten thousand twenty thousand years
ago I'm not sure exactly how far but a
long time ago that the Anunnaki and the
reptilians were on the planet and the
Galactic Federation came in and they
said all right you guys gotta go and the
Anunnaki said sure peace out and we're
gone and the reptilians were like no no
we don't want to leave and they said
okay but you can't be seen by the humans
and that's when they went underground
and they operate through Consciousness
now
so they kind of still run the plan they
still kind of live here and run the
planet through Consciousness but they're
not seen necessarily that yeah I mean a
lot of that is in the phys is definitely
in the vicinity of Truth where we're
touching on it I mean the the reptilians
apparently believe that they own the
planet they've got some type of claim
that they say they have
um they appear to have
okay well it's a strange story but part
of the briefings I've gotten is that
the moon was put in place 65 million
years ago and there's some debate as to
whether it was then or a lot more recent
but I don't know if they really know but
they're one of the theories is the moon
was put in place
to bring about the fall of the dinosaurs
to create Seasons that the Moon is a
spaceship that it could have it was
flown into position it orbits the earth
and in so doing mammalian life now
predominates whereas before it was
reptilian life
and uh the reptilians had you know the
the dinosaur species apparently did
evolve into a hominid race that was
intelligent
that got wiped out when this took place
the 65 million year ago incident and
they did get driven underground so that
is a that is a classic element of the
story but then the Draco Alliance the
the negative ETS
say that you know we persecuted the
reptilians we we you know traumatized
them we drove them underground and now
we have to pay tribute we have to pay
rent to be here
and so the the treaty the negative
treaty is that we're apparently giving
them
uh humans as our meat suits yeah for
whatever they want to use us for whether
they want to line on us or have us as
workers or whatever
um they we trade a certain number of
humans per year
and uh it's it's disturbing and it's the
kind of thing that once people get the
absolute facts about it and they find
out you know and nobody's holding your
hand anymore but they're saying yeah
this is what's really going on
well how do you stay safe if some if
some crazy reptile man could come and
grab you how do you stay safe well
again this is all we're in a spiritual
reality and
the the the the negative side is pushing
all this Satanism because it wants us to
embrace it and if enough of us embraced
it then it could become
embodied on Earth
you know but it'll never happen people
do not like this and they don't
what we're seeing is the exposure of the
negative and this is a very very
fascinating and prolonged thing that's
still ongoing where
they've become so blatant that everybody
is talking about it uh
where we can't ignore
the sense of Terror that these events
are causing we're left feeling
very vulnerable and very concerned about
you know is the world going to be safer
are these people going to win in
whatever they're trying to do and yeah
there is
a negative evil Consciousness these
these entities
from rigel these Draco reptilians
they want on any Planet they go to to
create you know pentagrams and ritual
magic and sacrifices and all this is
just what they do wow you know it's it's
just their culture so is the Illuminati
real and is the Illuminati sort of the
indoctrinated
um ritualistic group of extensions of
that Draco reptilian that are here to
take over oh yeah I mean
all right you if you've ever I'm not
going to get specific but if somebody
Danica has ever come up to you
and they shake your hand but there's
like something odd about their fingers
while they're doing it it's not quite a
normal handshake but there's something a
little odd they're pushing in this I'm
not going to be specific but
if you ever have noticed something like
that like well they kind of came in
weird or you know why were they pushing
over there well that's because
handshakes are one of the most common
ways in which people can find out if if
you are involved so they might like
do this particular grip look you very
intensely in the eyes and say are you
family are you family are you family
look at her I don't even want to like
try to out you if that ever happened to
you but the point is it does and they
test for people but if you don't have
the right hand Shaker if you don't say
yes I'm family or whatever it is
then you know they know that you're not
and so there's a lot of Secrets they use
to keep this thing hidden from people
but like
it's very sad because you know the they
teach that betrayal is the first rule of
the order so even children are being
traumatized very severely by their own
parents uh they're forced to go through
MK Ultra hypnotic programming torture
programming electroshocks they they
almost all basically all of them are
going to go through some type of Mind
programming experiences and they don't
really understand what they're working
for you know the the the basis of the
negative is deception and so the
negative tells you if you work with us
we'll give you what you want but in the
process you've lost your soul and that's
why every type of story that has to do
with
getting lower astrals to solve your
wishes it always turns out badly so in
my own experience Danica I've had
multiple invitations to this group
I've had bribes in the billions of
dollars that were offered to me I mean
Greers talks about getting bribed for
billions too I've interviewed him a
couple of times when you go out there
and you're in involved in this stuff
like I am
they really would love to have you on
their side they really would love to
have you as a mouthpiece and and so I
was told for example
that I could do everything the way I do
it now
and the only thing that I would have to
do different in order to get this money
is to quote unquote speak favorably
about Lucifer and they have this
philosophy they wanted people to talk
about
which is that you know well Lucifer is
is a benevolent misunderstood angel
and
God abandoned us up in heaven but
Lucifer stayed down here with us
look any God that tells you you got to
go around hurting people is not a God I
want to be involved with right this
isn't just hurting people this is like
the most insane evil and so
for me to be able to wrap my head around
how this type of stuff could be
happening in the world
I went back to brain physiology I looked
at the at the physiology of the
psychopath
as I majored in Psychology in college
and we found out that
some people have this uh condition in
their brain where large parts of the
brain don't even operate they're not
there's whole entire regions of the
brain that don't function
and this includes uh most of the whole
area of the frontal cortex it includes
the hippocampus it includes
um all kinds of stuff the in insula is
another one there's a bunch of them in
my new book I have 17 regions of the
brain I found
that all shut down
so it turns out that
once you have this type of a brain
abnormality
you will typically have narcissism you
will typically have a very expanded
sense of of yourself
but at your core you have these
maladaptive patterns
that make you impossible to have a
relationship with
your competitive you're
um you know very jealous
they uh they want to control other
people and they and they build up an
elaborate deception they lie they create
a false reality
they can mimic human emotions very well
but they don't really feel them the same
way that we do
and so this is the criminal psychology
it's it's the psychology of a majority
of all the people that are incarcerated
most of them have psychopathy
statistically speaking
and and there are very real brain
abnormalities that you know make them
unable to evaluate the morality of their
decisions and when you're encountering
these types of people
uh it's it's very disconcerting because
they're so good at telling you exactly
what you want and making you feel like
you're amazing and building up your ego
and you talked about like pain too and I
wonder if part of these brain shutdowns
another weird thing that you see people
compile is these images of public
figures that all have you know a black
eye and it's always the left eye or
something and they all have like I saw
one recently that they all have uh
spraying it like an ankle boot like on
the same leg like it's like oh maybe
within these ritualistic practices they
are literally hurting each other like I
don't or some something I don't know oh
you could get beat up too I mean that
you know people in these groups are not
treated very well uh even the you know
the Rothschild supposedly run this and
they get treated like crap by the Draco
my Insider Jacob was in the meetings
where Draco would meet with the
Rothschilds directly and you know the
these these these aliens do not respect
us at all
they look at this as their property they
look at humans as uh slaves
and they don't They Don't Care About Us
they're not interested in making anybody
rich or making anybody happy and so it's
not like if somebody has all this money
from being in this group that they have
a happy life their life is so horrible
when you want to do these awful things
it's because your brain has been damaged
and and there are ways in which the
brain can heal I mean in my book I talk
about like yoga breath work meditation
athletic activity going out in nature
all these things will actually reverse
it over time how do we shift out of this
shift the momentum in a direction and I
think it already is going that way I
think while people think it's worse than
ever right now it's also better than
ever in some ways polarity I think is
always at play and I think that it's
more we know more than we've ever known
for the for the better it's negative
things so what is the what is the
transition into this next phase where we
get out of this reptilian sort of
um control or influence and on our
planet and is this part of what the new
Earth concept is I've asked so many
people along the way like is this new
like what is the new Earth is that
something that is part of this
transition right now and and how do we
get there what does that look like this
is definitely the right time to bring up
Michael prophecies which you'd asked me
to talk about before we got on the air
so
um it's a big subject but I wanna I
wanna dive into it so yeah yeah we
talked about evil and we talked about
the idea there are these evil beings but
then I have a movie that we're doing
right now Hollywood film the movie's
called levitation and when I was doing
Ancient Aliens there was one thing that
I was explicitly forbidden by the parent
network from ever discussing they would
not ever let me talk about it on the
show
it's the idea that Angels might be
extraterrestrials or vice versa I was
explicitly forbidden from analogizing
extraterrestrials and angels together
and why is that so another thing that I
was explicitly forbidden from talking
about by any media entity was levitating
Saints that's here interesting enough
okay so it turns out that if you go back
through time
and you look at these people who were
reading the Bible
and some you know I've already talked
about Tibet so it's not just
Christianity it can happen in other
cultures too but the point is if you
have a dedicated spiritual practice
which can include people that were
Christian Saints
there's people who get canonized they
get they they get sainted because their
body lifted up into the air in front of
other people there's cases of people
making their faces glow with light uh
and and like there's a lot of really
specific fascinating unique information
like this
and nobody will let you talk about it
you can't talk about it at all
so I made them I'm working on this movie
called levitation which goes into that
and the reason I'm bringing this up is
that again we get into the concept that
when you meditate on things like
patience forgiveness love
uh
then
you you somehow
become
what the universe is is actually made of
the the Tibetans again said empty
awareness is the is the nature of the
universe so you're becoming that empty
awareness you're becoming that
uh Consciousness which then allows you
to have control over our illusion so
that's the that's part of the positive
side you know we we talk about evil we
talk about demons we talk about
reptilians blood drinking Satanism oh my
God it's so scary but
then you got people levitating who are
practicing reading the Bible you got
people in Tibet pushing their hands into
the stone pushing their foot into rock
and it's because not that they were
going around being some jerk and killing
people and trying to you know draw
pentagrams but because they're actually
loving patient
you know
and they they're they're doing their
part to embody compassion in their
essence
um so
it appears that the real nature of why
we're here is to learn those lessons
and
so let's cut back to when my career
started I started out I was born in 1973
so I'm 50 years old
I got online in 1996
and I first had Art Bell was was the big
thing back then the UFO community
and he was talking about remote viewing
all the time that there were these
military uh protocols
where you can screen out your conscious
mind and pick up
uh a remote location
and then look at that remote location
with your mind's eye whatever that is
and actually describe it correctly and
the best remote viewers like Joe
mcmonagle would be 99 accurate and they
did this for decades
military they would look at you know
businesses and things Stanford research
international SRI International you know
there was a whole branch of remote
viewing coming out of that
well many years later in 2009 I met Dr
Pete Peterson one of the Insiders who is
probably the highest ranking American
Insider I have
and uh I mean he worked in all kinds of
really strange stuff all kinds of exotic
technology that's based on reverse
engineering crashed UFOs
and it's it's considered common
knowledge to them that
there are these meta-humans that used to
be on earth that the Earth used to be
populated by much more powerful beings
than how we are now that we fell from
this state
and that we are going to return to that
state
and that the events that are taking
place on Earth right now
are part of a Great Awakening which is
very spring-loaded you know like you
think a Jack In The Box and you crank
that wheel and Bam it eventually comes
out
it that's kind of like what's going to
happen to us with our bodies how will
this occur like what's the shift like so
say there's an there's a there's a
there's a split you know the people that
don't want to that don't have the
Consciousness level and the frequency to
go to the next level the next Dimension
the next energy field the new Earth that
um they'll maybe become invisible like
as an energy like we see and hear on
such a small Spectrum maybe they just
aren't part of our reality anymore but
they're here right but we're all living
our own lives in different places or
will there be some kind of a actual
planetary split and there'll be an
environment that they just won't exist
in and it'll be sort of like and we'll
just we'll maybe they'll disappear we'll
wake up and they'll be gone and it'll be
like a great mental reset where we get
like it's um Men In Black you hit the
button and you don't remember like maybe
there's just a splice in time like you
say you get picked up on a ship and you
come back and they splice you right in
are we just gonna get spliced into a new
reality and we won't know there was any
change obviously I've thought about this
a bit I can see I mean it's you asking
me this question now in August of 2023
you're going to get a very different
answer than you would have before
February of 2022. I started remote
viewing in 1996
and I skipped right to getting spoken
words
and this was a technique called The
Dream voice that I learned from a guy
met online in the Richard C Hogan Forum
he was talking about the face on Mars
Hoagland was the top guy in Art Bell
they had 20 million listeners a night if
you got on this show you were set you
know you could sell tons and tons of
products it's like jackpot business
basically right so
that wasn't why I want to do it but of
course like if you could get on Art Bell
and yet your 20 million listeners and
you got your hot product and you pushed
the product bam it's gonna go crazy so
Oakland was the top guy I sought him out
for a long time I was on his forum and I
met a guy on the Forum who had this
technique called The Dream voice
and he said when you wake up in the
morning and you can first still remember
what your dream was
you might hear something talking and it
might be like it's over on your left and
there might be another one behind you
and it's kind of like there's a TV on in
the other room and if you listen to it
you can sort of kind of make out a
little of what it says and you might get
like half a sentence and it's going to
sound weird it doesn't make any sense
and that's perfect rabbit just like it
is word for word dictate it into your
tape recorder
or write it down on paper was what I did
the first time
so the next morning after he taught me
about this dream voice technique I woke
up
and I found that I could do it and I
could hear what sounded like his voice
I'd heard this stuff before
you just think it's like imagination but
you train yourself so that when your
mind is totally tuned out
you learn how to receive a spontaneous
impression
in other words you have to learn how to
blank yourself
and then what you become aware of is no
the thoughts that I'm having are
important you know people think oh I'm
supposed to meditate I'm not supposed to
have any thoughts you get to this ground
state you get to this meditative State
and then all this data and information
starts to appear in the form of visual
images emotional Impressions and words
and so a lot of times the words will
also have the visual images and the
emotional Impressions attached to them
so I started to do this process where
I'm listening to something talking and
I'm writing it down
and I'm following all the protocols of
remote viewing which means I don't
analyze it I don't have any emotional
reaction I don't have to pee I don't
have to go to the bathroom I don't I'm
not hungry I'm not thirsty
so my body is comfortable I I'm very
relaxed I have no negative emotions
and I blank out my mind you get to mind
awake body of sleep you feel like your
body is stiff like it's almost like it
could float
and you get to that very very pure
Consciousness and then in that state you
start listening
and the dream voices that you'll get
these very weird sentences that don't
make sense and you want it to sound
weird you don't want it to sound like
well hi Danica how are you today you
know I mean the bottom line is that I
dictated
over 3000 pages of this stuff between
1999 and two or between 96 and 2000.
and it began predicting the future
with remarkable Clarity
um the very first day that I did it it
said one of our women Teresa a sibling
inoperative the Christians psychically
and then like five days later Mother
Teresa has a heart attack
and I was freaking Blown Away
I mean that was the very first time I
did it
and
it starts to get scary after a while
because every time I'd sit down to
transcribe new cassette tapes I was
doing it on 90 minute cassette tapes at
the time
uh they would be describing what was
happening right before I sat down even
though I dictated him let's say three
weeks ago
so
to get through a whole lot of of story
um I did this for four years pretty much
full time I was always you know
dictating transcribing I started to do
clients
I did a total of 500 clients between 98
and 2005 or 2004.
I did a tour of Japan and I had a whole
bunch of clients in Japan
people were starting to get like uh
darshan off of me I was touching
people's hands and they'd get like oh
they'd start crying and shaking and all
this stuff
so weird things can happen when you give
these readings to people
um
there's a very intense Cosmic presence
that comes in the room as my body is
speaking
when they speak they use a lot of
symbolism they use a lot of word
pictures they're always painting
pictures with their words and as a
result
the experience that you have
is is Hypnotic and you get hypnotized to
such a degree where you're having full
visual
internal Visions all the time while
they're talking and and typically
another weird side effect is that
uh the the I don't know what it is
exactly we're not really sure but you
always end up having to pee really bad
when it's over maybe because your brain
is overclocking or something I'm not
sure the brain uses a lot of calories
but well if you're if you're channeling
the good guys which I would hope
everybody would do
um then at that point they what they
really want from you is is to be a good
person you know and if you have
distortions in your personality
the biggest danger is if you're if
you're going to work with these guys
and they and they give teachings through
you and then you're gonna
behind closed doors it turns out that
you're a real jerk and you're yelling
and you're ripping people off and your
character is in deficit from what you're
saying that you are that's lethal that
could get you killed if you're doing
this kind of work that I'm doing so it I
I my life is on the line as far as being
a good person I have to be a good person
I have to be honest I have to tell the
truth I have to not rip people off not
do criminal Behavior because the stakes
are so high uh so just to finish this
discussion about the channeling thing
I did I posted this stuff beginning in
1999 is when I got a website so all of
the results that I had I put online for
the most part there's a little bit that
I didn't in 98. uh but I have multiple
forensically dateable forms of that in
cassette tapes I have it in printouts I
have it in hard drives with saved files
that you can time stamp so nobody can
dispute when these readings were created
and it was uh in September 2021
that I remembered that there was
something in the readings that said
uh that there would be a coup over the
military industrial complex and it's
Stranglehold over UFO secrecy
a coup or the military what the
I mean that's just like
a coup over the how do you even have a
coup over the military industrial
complex so you know you get these
strange words and they say all these
strange things and it's like you just
keep writing it down and that was one of
the things they said
and I I'm looking at all this and I'm
like you know there does appear to be
some kind of war going on in the world
where you have Donald Trump and and
they're constantly going after this guy
they're attacking him with everything
they got and then people are like well
is it just Trump no there's there's this
group that's working with him
and so you got to think differently and
say well
is it really just this one guy or is it
that there's this initiative
that that that the military is working
on
to safely
Expose and defeat the Deep State and
that is exactly what I believe is going
on and it's it's a very complicated very
intense subject
but
I believe the reason why we're learning
all of this is because we're in some
sort of information War disclosure War
they never wanted us to know the the
Insiders never wanted you to know
about Lucifer Satan
they did you know I mean they might have
put it in movies here and there but like
what we're what they're doing now is an
act of desperation
when you see them going out so much to
advertise this is not coming from a
place of strength
they work out of deception they work out
of subterfuge they work out of
infiltration uh posing as the good guy
not being honest you know gaining your
trust gaining control of your money
gaining control of your personal power
and then manipulating you
because the ultimate goal of the
negative is to get you to have a
character change where you consciously
choose to do bad things yeah and if we
could say a they and they might not want
to say who I mean I know we're talking
about the Draco reptilian sort of
corruption and influence but who would
the they sort of faces be right now that
are trying so hard to maintain this
the status quo and the secrecy
well you could think of it as a bank you
could think of it as an organization you
could think but but the the key as Jacob
or Uncle Jack you know used to say night
it's all about the vertical integration
right because he's Australian so he
would tell me that to really understand
this you have to understand you have to
try to imagine like let's go back to the
Swiss scientific study of Dr James
glatfelder and I've written about this
before
in uh he graduated from the Financial
Institute of Technology in in
Switzerland which is very very
prestigious University fit
and they used a super computer and they
analyzed this and they published this
paper in 2010 they analyzed
a database of all the world's
transnational corporations and there's
about 40 000 of them and this was in
it's called orbis 2007 was the name of
the database
well it gets really crazy because what
they found out was that
there was this thing called a super
entity they called it a super entity
they found
136 corporations we're in a super entity
that earned eighty percent of all the
wealth to be earned in the world
familiar
doesn't that sound familiar 80 percent
of all the wealth in the world can be
earned by
136 corporations who secretly control
the other ones with all this disguised
stuff that they had to use super
computers to dig out
like there's one guy on the board of
directors on this company but he's also
on he's on the banking company he's on
the media company he's on the
pharmaceutical company he's on the
military company you know it's that kind
of stuff
so well wait a minute like what are
these 136 companies well three quarters
of them turn out to be financial
institutions
oh isn't that interesting okay so then
then when we go back to the Libor
Scandal that broke in 2012 and I hope
I'm not dropping too many keywords for
our video but you know they found out
that and this was publicly announced
that
the big Financial entities were
appearing to be in competition with each
other
when in fact they knew what their rates
were going to be and it was all rigged
and fixed
they were rigging the the rates between
these Banks yeah so it's like well
that means investing is totally fake
it's all based on what they want to
happen
I've always thought that the stock
market and all that stuff just seems
like it's just puppets right this goes
up that goes down that goes down bring
that up like it's just all just a chess
match to keep it in bounds well yes so
so the first step is okay can you can
you see
136 Financial entities or most of them
are 136 Mega corporations
earning eighty percent of the money in
the world can you see that okay then if
you can see that
can you see that the people in these 136
companies are all friends if their
friends are they an occult well I mean
if you look up the definition of cult
it's going to have a lot of those things
they got like their their group they
meet all the time they have a secret
language they do particular activities
what lingers in this group is occultism
and ritual Magic
and you don't have to be in any religion
to participate in luciferianism but
that's what they're doing and again
if you can imagine this
the people who are in these Elite
circles that are running these
corporations
are dressing up in robes and masquerade
ball masks
and they're having orgies and they're
drinking blood from people who've been
traumatized which causes hallucinations
and the hallucinations are of these
entities that appear in the room
now I still don't really know honestly
whether those things that they're seeing
exist
as a tangible reality or whether it's a
hallucination
um
I know there's some people who
absolutely believe it's a corporeal
thing
and that could be but
again like
if you are dumb enough to do something
like this
you are playing around with an entity
that can kill you very easily
so
when you learn about this and you learn
about people who start messing around
with the demonic
if you have a demon that's that's on
your case man it can you it can really
make your life terrible it can just I
mean this is this is something real you
know
so
the people who play around with this
like wow it's just such a it's such a
stupid thing to do
because you know what
but but the problem is you get into a
culture
and you're you're brought up in it from
birth you know people this is a
generational cult so you're born into it
basically
they've been traumatizing you in utero
they'll do things that they believe that
the psychopathic brain the split brain
you know when you have a psychopath
the criminal personality they have two
personalities they have their normal
waking personality and that's the one
that you fall in love with and that's
the one that you think you're gonna
marry and whatever
and then there's another one in there
which is the trauma self
and and when you have a person with this
disorder they can appear normal but if
they get triggered then they behave very
inappropriately
and they'll act in ways that are highly
selfish and and unacceptable and um
you know I studied it in college and we
can see lots of examples in the world
today so once you have this brain
abnormality like I was talking about
when your brain is psychopathic uh
you're more apt to well there's a part
of the brain called the striatum
which is along the central area near the
corpus callosum
and this is this this part of the brain
uh lights up in pleasure in the minds of
psychopaths when they see other people
getting hurt
isn't that interesting we now have a
scientific way to show
that when you have this type of a brain
you do take pleasure in violence
so you know these reptilians are
seemingly it would you'd think they're
promising them something like you say
they come they come to fruition you see
them they're like what do you want and
you know it sure looks like uh we're
gonna make you rich We're Gonna Make You
Famous your album's going number one
whatever the thing is you've already
probably found out what a big bunch of
crap that is I mean famous is tough man
I met all the rock stars in the 80s and
none of them were happy Danica I can
tell you no no no the it's always an
inside job nothing in general the more
you get on the outside actually the less
you the less you feel good on the inside
for the most part or at least you can
have a wave of that like I've had
moments where you like get sad for like
a little sad about something your life
and you're like I have everything and
you're almost thinking contrast to the
inside it just doesn't match
um so it can kind of emphasize it but
you know well it's funny right I called
it Elvis Maryland syndrome we're trained
to think that if we hit the highest
level of of publicity
that it's like that scene at the end of
the Hollywood movie where it says Danica
Patrick reached 25 zillion people you
know whoa holy crap she's so amazing
no that life actually kind of sucks
no and so I've spent two years doing the
Paul McCartney thing like what he did
after the Beatles I've just been living
by myself alone on my land
dealing with animals and bears and
turkeys and and writing these books and
you know I needed to get away from it
because it had hurt my brain I had had
some degree of damage
from just being
the just the unrelenting stress and
torture like you know you reminded me
years there was years of my career where
I gotta sell three conference tickets at
300 a day I got to make a thousand
dollars a day every day I gotta watch my
numbers and if I ever start making less
than a thousand dollars a day I'm
screwed and I gotta immediately start
marketing and pushing and just like oh I
got to get right back into it again so
you just feel like you know oh they're
not paying enough attention to me
anymore what do I do
I hate that stuff supposed to put a
swimsuit on and post the picture okay oh
that's what you do that's it's sex cells
always has great thank you that's that's
very helpful information
I definitely don't go to that well very
often unless it naturally happens in my
life
um which isn't that often
um okay well let's moving into these
books zero five is that right five
channel books that are published and
there's seven that are going to come out
all together yeah okay so what is this
future information like what did you
learn about our future
well as I was saying I got this remote
viewing information from 96 to 2000 and
then beginning in September 2021
I remembered that it said there was
going to be a coup over the military
industrial complex well how's that even
possible
well the people who are behind Donald
Trump are also in possession of this UFO
technology one of the names is majestic
and uh Majestic 12 was the original
group that was assigned over the Roswell
crash so
there's been this Insider War for a long
time between Majestic and the Illuminati
where the Illuminati wanted to reduce
population by three quarters or
two-thirds whatever I mean I imagine
you've been in a relationship with
psychopath I have to so you you've been
through all this they don't want you
strong and healthy right like when are
you going to have a fight with a
psychopath you're going to have a fight
with a psycho the most dangerous thing
you can say is I'm tired
right if you say I'm tired holy you
could be in trouble because they're
going to wait until you're at your
weakest point they don't the psychopath
doesn't want you healthy they need a
broken down weakened person
so that they can have control over you
so the reason why they want the Earth's
population lower is that they want us
they want us sick they want us fat they
want us diseased
they want us easily controlled because
that's the habitat in which demonics
could then ultimately walk among us if
they could get us to go that far into
evil that is their goal Bill Gates is
Bill Gates the devil because he seems to
be buying everything to poison us I
believe that he's he's
operating in on behalf of this greater
cultic group whose goal is again they
don't think they're evil I mean you
gotta understand they look at what
they're doing as some sort of benevolent
step for Humanity yeah they're
malthusian now malthusian Doctrine is
that the population bomb is going to
explode and it's going to go from 8
billion to 20 billion to 50 billion and
all of a sudden bam the whole world is
gone that's their Theory but it turns
out that we have so much more natural
resource here than we're using the
technology is going to be released to us
and that's why I built stavati well
co-founded savati Aerospace with
Christopher bescar
we're doing those Technologies we he
worked at these classified programs with
Pete Peterson
and so we can do power plants which is
uh free energy
we we have levitation systems so we're
going to have spaceships we have
these Technologies are not uh they're
not Superstition they're not sci-fi they
do exist they've just been withheld from
us by the National Security State up
until now
but that's changing
um is there a reason like what is that
can you is there a way to put your
finger on the reason why they've
withheld this stuff for so long is it
just money I mean it probably is just
money but is there a reason
well first of all you got to see that if
you have the super entity of 136
corporations is run by a cult as I said
the cult is run by
extraterrestrial evil entities
and and so there's extraterrestrial
versions of this and there's demonic
versions of this the extraterrestrials
are more like flesh and blood the
demonics are more like some sort of
entity thing from lower astral
that you can see if you go through this
particular occult ritual
um and only really under those
conditions
why would they want to hurt us it's not
really the people in these groups agenda
it's somebody else's agenda they're
following somebody else's agenda they're
getting their benefit which is to drink
from the cup of abundance to have all
the wealth to have all the sex to have
all the stuff they think they want
they want to drink from that cup but
that you you're losing your soul
and they're but but what we really
haven't seen yet is that because there's
very Advanced extraterrestrials doing
all this
they have it really dialed in
they are in control
of a lot of what's going on here on
planet Earth this is not being run by
people this is being run by
extraterrestrials
and they their their personality their
style what they like is Satanism so
that's what they would like to see the
Earth turn into is a satanic planet and
so they're they're putting the pedal to
the metal right now because the mass
Awakening that we're experiencing is the
opposite we're we're taking those steps
towards the Tibetan rainbow body
in other words when the Deep State tries
to say
that because you over here are black and
you over here are white
that there's this systemic oppression
you all should be fighting each other
and getting into a big Civil War that's
divide and conquer it's
um they're gonna do everything they can
to try to find
marginalized groups disenfranchise
populations people who feel like they've
never ever been treated with respect and
they want to reel you in that way it's
it's a coalition
of
people who were not given their respect
before
why does it seem so obvious to some and
not others what's going on again we get
back to the idea that the human
the human DNA is very very similar to
the Animal Kingdom
and we have all these unique behaviors
and these unique
uh things that we do that are
animalistic in nature and and the
biggest one is follow the leader
so is there more like extraterrestrial
blood and people that don't think that
it's that that it is obvious to like
that you have a benevolent
benevolent entity
blood you're you're speculating on
something that I do have solid data for
Pete Peterson once told me that the the
Jesuits the the Catholic priest sect I
guess that that particular sect has 25
alien DNA is what he said the Jesuits
have 25 of alien DNA
but a lot of us on Earth do
and he said that the more
of this of this so-called alien DNA or
extraterrestrial is probably a better
word they don't really want to be called
aliens because most of them look like us
they're people the more of that you have
you you just you have a faster flicker
frequency that's one of the things you
you will process frames of vision faster
and you cannot be brainwashed with
propaganda so yeah there is definitely
we you know they say that there's five
different poor human races that came out
on Earth pretty much at the same time
they tried to trace it all to one
mitochondrial eve
where the mitochondria of one mother
supposedly is everybody on Earth they
wanted that for the Bible but you know
that's not right yeah we get five unique
groups
we get five groups that all popped in at
the same time and apparently you know we
are descendants of extraterrestrial
humans that were on other planets before
they crash landed here or they modified
existing primates on Earth with their
DNA right right and yeah there are
different types of people with different
types of DNA and it makes sense because
it totally seems like while there's the
satanic ones the ritualistic there's the
more benevolent there's also what I
totally feel like is like non-player
characters there's so many NPCs in the
world that are happy with literally not
evolving not thinking a new thought not
going past the the just step and repeat
style living right where it's just the
same thing every day in a non-inspiring
location with non-inspiring activities
like it just is
so mediocre
I think a lot of that is fear I think
those people
so so there's a very significant thing I
talk about in in Michael prophecy's book
one and that's the Sheep effect
and
when you look at the fact that our DNA
is evolved from prey animals to some
degree
Hollywood has reinforced this
programming in our minds in many many
movies and in the movie you have
somebody hiding under the bed
and what is the lesson in every time
that happens the lesson is God damn it
if you hadn't looked at his feet you
wouldn't have gotten killed if you
looked at his eff and feet then you get
scared and you go oh God and then you
bump on the bed and then he pulls the
bed away and Wham he starts stabbing you
put the blinders on
yeah yeah so
uh when you think about that
the Sheep develop a herd Instinct in
which they know that the wolf is
circling around the herd
but
the wolf doesn't realize that they know
until somebody looks at him
so whatever a-hole looks at him is the
one that broke it for everybody
if you just keep your goddamn head down
don't do anything and don't say anything
and don't pretend that you know that the
wolf is there he won't attack you so we
have this so so what the negative tries
to do
is it tries to trigger us into our
trauma self which means we're going
through
a heightened emotional state we have
emotional arousal we have we have our
heart rate going up we have the you know
the kinetic feeling of butterflies on
your skin your hair is standing up you
have sweat and your pores coming out
you have an accelerated uh all of your
physiologies is up your brain waves your
heart rate your respiratory pattern
and then in that condition
you're in fight or flight
and what when you go into fight or
flight we know that the cerebrum and
most of the brain is not being used
if you can keep somebody afraid you can
keep somebody in fight or flight
they're running out of The Reptilian
core of their brain I was going to say
it's The Reptilian Brain and they don't
have the frontal lobes which means
they're not thinking in terms of
morality and ethics anymore no so if you
can keep people scared you activate this
sheep program which says
don't you dare look at the evil because
if you do it's going to start chasing
you oh and wait it's even better than
that Danica because if you're the a-hole
who looks at the wolf
you're terrified when he starts chasing
you he he comes at you with his teeth
and everything and so you're the one who
goes into this coma where like for a few
seconds you can't move and so you're the
one who ends up dying
so the animal kingdom teaches you that
if you look at evil you will die and the
Sheep know this which is why they never
look at it
so what we really have here is a mass
manipulation
of humanity and in order for the formula
to work
they have to have the if it bleeds it
leads they have to keep the fear yeah
there has to always be something that
terrifies you yeah the war on terror
right it never ends it's just this
ambiguous thing that we're at war with
this kind of leads in like leads into a
little bit of a conversation about this
secret spaceship program and
you know
anti-gravity technology and being able
to fly around and does this lead to
getting off planet is this actually
something is this something we need to
do is this part of human salvation
yeah I I'll give you an exclusive here
something that nobody's heard before
um
our secret space program or whatever you
want to call it that's a good name for
it they
've already gone out there and been
throughout space and one of the things
that we're going to learn is that there
is a beautiful planet that's less than
10 light years away from us I think it's
like seven or nine light years away and
they call it the Hawaii planet and
there's a bunch of very peaceful cool
people living there humans of different
types and it's all the whole planet is
like Hawaii and it just it's it's just
apparently
like the best that you could imagine
about Hawaii but then like way better
you know and so we already have places
we can go
and the the extraterrestrials again
let's get back to Michael prophecies
because that kind of ties it all
together
when I was doing all this stuff in the
1990s I had no idea
what it was really saying because I
would stay in trance when I dictated it
I would stay in transform I transcribed
it
and then when I would even like post it
online I'd make subheadings I just kind
of look at the words and look for some
strange phrase and just make that the
subheading I wasn't even really reading
it so I never really read this stuff
and then I got busy you know Hoagland
and I ended up working together directly
we went on our Bell together in 2004
that's when my career really started to
get a lot bigger
uh and I got a book deal I ended up
having New York Times best-selling
author twice I had you know Ancient
Aliens a bunch of those shows so
I did all this other stuff and I'd
forgotten about all this work that I did
in the 90s until September 2021 and I
saw this quote and then in in February
I really began reading this stuff
and it's talking about everything that's
going on now
and what it said is that
in the Bible and in these other ancient
religious texts you know there's over 30
of them 35 different texts according to
santiana vanderson these historians all
talking about that there's going to be
the end of the world
that there's going to be
you know
some type of ele extinction level event
where there's like a pole shift or
there's a tsunami or there's a sun gives
off this big flash of heat and radiation
and we all get cooked by that and that
has happened many times on earth right
uh there have been these types of
geological disasters we know that we can
go look at the
smashed up bodies of of sloths and giant
mammals like mastodons ah I just
interviewed Randall Carlson and and when
he dicted like give us some timeline and
stuff you're like holy it's just
lucky we're here because oh yeah
it hasn't been that long since it was
completely different and that we were
wiped out and everybody in these ancient
prophecies the vast majority of them
there's a few that kind of got around it
Islam and
Zoroastrianism pretty much but other
than those
they all kind of say the same thing
they're all expecting like some big
catastrophe
the Earth will reel to and fro like a
drunkard you know
um the the stars fall from their
positions in the sky
this implies of massive catastrophic
Earth movement
and if the Earth moves very much then
you're going to get massive massive
hurricanes that will just destroy most
of the surface structures 200 mile an
hour winds I mean pole shift is a very
serious thing 80 80 foot high tsunami
coming across America yeah you don't
want that
you know so super volcano goes off right
like Yellowstone Caldera and these are
real concerns I mean we're looking at
the world and we're saying yeah there's
definitely things like this have
happened yeah and you have all these
prophecies that tell us oh you know we
know exactly when that is going to
happen
well no uh what we're now getting from
my information Michael prophecies is
first of all the source is claiming to
be Archangel Michael now that doesn't
even the name doesn't even appear until
book six the one I'm working on right
now
and I would have been working on it
except that when I saw that we want to
do this interview this is the first like
serious interview for YouTube I've done
in two years
you know I know that's why I started off
by going where have you been
well
I got trapped into this archangelic
thing where they need me to write these
books for them and I don't have any
other choice
and I had it just took it's just taking
a really long time but
when you actually get into these books I
mean there's five of them right now
people are reading the comments we're
getting are phenomenal
um
they've done something I've never seen
or heard of before which is
there's Prophecies of all the different
things that are happening in the world
today
and they do it so redundantly Kamala
Harris Joe Biden whatever is happening
with Trump with the documents the
indictments I mean you name it it's the
Afghanistan thing the Ukraine thing
they've got zelenski in there everything
everything that's going on and it's just
shocking and I mean I'm gonna go back
and be reading it again and still find
stuff I haven't seen before
so these prophecies are are so redundant
that I I said well okay I'm gonna put
them in red
and you know we got five books so the
first five books the first four are all
over 500 pages long
and then books uh five six and seven are
all going to be around 333 pages
so it's like over three thousand pages
in total uh but every book that you pick
up is going to be just totally
mind-blowing
um so
this is all I've been doing for for two
years so there's so much intellectual
property or IP in this stuff
that I probably have 10 years worth of
movies and television shows I can make
off of this now
in terms of all the different things
I've done and all the different rocks I
turned over and all the different
research I found it's just amazing
what's in this
and and and I wanted to be worthy of the
message because what they said is look
you guys have avoided a catastrophic
Earth change we found a way to get you
to go through history
without needing to have a pole shift
so the first pole shift that was
prophesied was 1998 Edgar Casey right
what they say in these books and now
we're into I believe book five
I think so
is that
in 1998 we had the Bill Clinton Monica
Lewinsky scandal
and the president of the United States
was implicated in a sex scandal where he
said I did not have sex with that woman
and then it was proven well depends on
what you want to call sex brother you
know and kind of some things you could
do with that cigar and just put it out
there but okay then turns out he's lying
right okay he's freaking lying ah he's
lying he did it
what they told me in these books what
they're telling us which I really didn't
even know about until last year
I mean I remember seeing this but not in
any depth
is that if we had all hated Clinton
and said he's an adulterer he's a
philanderer he's a pervert we need to
see him not be president we need to see
him get thrown out you know we want to
see him go to jail or we want to see him
be executed firing squad treason
whatever you know if it had gone crazy
like that
then we would have had a pole shift in
our our planet would have been destroyed
because
we would have shown on a global level
that we did not learn the lesson of love
because we were not able to love Bill
Clinton
Believe It or Not wow so there was a big
test that we were going through in 1998
and 99 those were the two years that
really mattered where like if we
if we could be okay with the fact that
okay you know what people have
infidelity
people do these things and we're not
going to say he's a demon we're not
going to say he's a monster but we're
just going to handle this responsibly
you know
that's what allowed us to save our
planet believe it or not
wow just the energy of the negativity
would have been enough to create a pole
shift yes because there was a there was
a Grand Cross astrological alignment in
August 11 1999. oh wow where you have
this huge Cross of planets it's like a
big X formation in our solar system
and that energetic I guess would have
lensed in a pole shift if we had been if
we hadn't been loving enough there's
there's there's like a science of love
and if the love isn't high enough you
get catastrophic activity well it seems
like your energy then yeah right if if
if we if we were not prepared for what's
coming if we hadn't been
loving enough then it would have needed
to be stopped yeah pause what's
happening now is that the negative is
trying to establish dominion over the
Earth right right if the negative got
its way
you're going to have
reptilians
basically running a Prison Planet
and zapping you with the equivalent of
electronic cattle prods which are
actually nanotech that they've put in
your body
so the reason why the implant thing is
so scary is well what if they can just
electrically shock you if you don't
comply and it's already inside you
oh okay I'll do whatever you want
because I just shot myself oh my God
extraterrestrials want to control the
Earth and they want to turn it into a a
Hades they want turned into a you know
a hell world so I'll see you in Hawaii
not the Hawaii right now
but the planet Hawaii the Hawaiian
Planet oh we're doing that I mean you
know we we we half jokingly half
non-jokingly talked about like
evacuation plans but we don't need to
evacuate that's the point we're we're
going to get this plant back you know
because
what the what the Michael prophecies
tells us is that
because we have learned our lessons
we've been forgiving enough we've been
spared the Earth changes and instead
these entities
these Angelic beings allowed
the whole coveted thing to play out
so as as tragic and disgusting and
completely
insane as the whole covid package is
with all of the different layers that
you can go into with it
that whole thing that they did which is
now being exposed
saved us from a pole shift saved us from
a catastrophic end of the world
and it's explained in great detail in
the Michael prophecies everything about
kovid everything about there's so many
dreams I had about sickness and disease
and you know there was one dream where
everybody in New York was sick and the
garbage bags were piled over with
medical waste you know and so
I didn't want to create that reality so
like when I saw that there was all these
kind of indications that some disease
pandemic would happen in the future
in the 1990s when I'm seeing that I'm
like I don't want this I don't want this
to be true so I kind of just you know
left it alone but then when you come
back to it and you start reading it and
you're like oh
wow
so they're saying that you know
if if we hadn't have learned our lessons
that you know during the Clinton time we
would have lost our planet but now
it the the the Grand Cross of August 11
1999 that alignment one of the things
that happened really close before then
is we lost John F Kennedy Jr
and it was a dodgy thing man it's like
wait a minute
what's going on this guy's plane like he
crashed in perfectly good weather but
he's a great pilot and you tell me that
he couldn't fly his plane like so it it
appears that was airplane sabotage you
know
and I was all into it back then I was
all over the JFK thing JFK Jr so
that and then 911 in September 2001
these events actually saved our planet
because
like when JFK Jr got assassinated I
could tell it wasn't just a random crash
it's like well they don't want him to
run against George W bush
and apparently one of the Intel leaks
was that he had talked to somebody on
the phone said he's going to run for
president
and that's when they got him you know
because they don't want Kennedy being in
the presidency again
so
there's this very interesting thing
that's happened where
there's two realities that people now
live in on Earth there's the reality
that you're supposed to believe in
and then there's truth and they've never
been more different so what's the
timeline then on
um timeline for where we get the planet
back or we shift or transition into this
more benevolent space this more positive
place where we have The Reptilian
negative influence away from us also
then for like truly off planet
technology like what do you think the
timeline is for those two things so
Michael prophecies again you know you
got 3 000 Pages already and there's so
much data in these books and they go
into great detail I mean there's really
never been anything like this and so
they have very specific answers for that
it appears that maybe even before the
end of this year or definitely sometime
early next year at the latest but
sometime in the near future the very
near future you're looking at things
happening now in the news that are
building up to something I think people
are really afraid of that like well you
know
every time that something bad happens to
Biden they gotta indict Trump again
right that's part of what we're seeing
it's like well isn't that strange
okay well
why would they be going after Trump so
much and what is it that they're trying
to stop from happening
with these other things that are
happening to Biden you know what happens
if
okay well yeah now we're acknowledging
right he did it he did these bad things
okay
well
it's what they're really worried about
is are people going to figure out the
game
you know like like in the classic case
of the carnival
the carnival is a very wonderful analogy
of what the world is like under the Deep
state
and it's very fascinating
when you go into a carnival
everybody in the carnival is part of a
secret group that works together so like
if you have wrestlers in the carnival
and they pretend to hate each other
you have the face and you have the heel
the job of the heel is to get the crowd
as angry as possible without throwing
their chairs so they'll insult your town
they go up there they're supposed to be
hated
the job of the face is to tell your tell
you that your town is great and then
they have the stage wrestling match it's
all fake so nobody actually gets injured
and
uh the the face ultimately wins and then
people bet on them and they feel good
but they won money you know but in fact
you're just the one making all the money
and you stage the whole thing
so the carnival would have a main
attraction it would either be usually
the wrestling match or the girl show
so the wrestling match has a lot to do
with politics there's a face and a heel
the girl show is pornography uh there
would be a woman who would who would
come out and would
um you know do a strip tease type of
dance and then she'd have a bottle and
she'd say if you guys want to see me
dance with this bottle and nothing else
you got to pay more and come into the
back room
and then that would be
you know a more erotic thing that would
happen so they're basically doing uh
prostitution
um so that was a common element of the
carnival organized sex trafficking
and then you also have the snake oil
salesman you have a guy out there who's
got like literally snake oil and he says
it's going to make you healthy that's
where that comes from
but what we don't understand necessarily
is that every every event in the
carnival is rigged none of them actually
are fair
so when you come into the carnival if
you have a lot of money in the guy
that's at the ticket counter sees that
they tap you on the shoulder and you get
a mark You're Now the mark That's where
that comes from you have a chalk mark on
your shoulder
and you'll go around and like Okay so
let's give an example
there's an event where you're supposed
to take a hammer and hit the thing right
and then it goes up and opens the belt
yeah
so what the guy does is he's got this
Cable in his hand and he leans in like
this
and so they'll have like a child come up
and hit the thing and if you leave the
cable untouched if you leave it Loose
any child can hit the Bell right
and then they know you're the mark
because they see the chalk on your on
your shoulder so they see you coming
around
and and then they'll make it really easy
they'll give out several wins even maybe
three wins huh and you come up and then
they lean on the cable
and when he leans in on the cable he's
just standing like this now
you'll never ever ever be able to hit
that thing
even the strongest man you're gonna hit
it as hard as you can it's never going
to hit the Bell okay well that's one
example another example would be like
when you're shooting the balloons with
the dart gun they'll give you a gun that
shoots down into the left
or some of them gonna even change how it
shoots wrongly so even if you learn the
gun the gun keeps changing
uh you got the one where there's a
like a roulette wheel right and and the
roulette wheel you can you can magnetize
a particular uh thing on the wheel so
that the ball's Gonna Roll there so you
know the person can't win
so everything like that is rigged
and
the goal again you know they they have
this thing they call the k-fabe which is
um the the wrestlers speak to each other
in this Carnival speak
where they take the word and they kind
of jumble it around so be fake becomes
k-fabe
so like for example the wrestler like
the the face is never supposed to be
seen
acting friendly around the heel
so like Hulk Hogan should never be seen
hanging out with Andre the Giant you
don't want those guys in WrestleMania
hate each other
right they hate each other right
so of course it's like it's all staged
and the movements are staged and the
objective is to you know create this
entertainment but um
when we look at this and then we apply
it to what's happening with the Deep
state
the the public is now becoming aware of
this type of an analogy that like wait a
minute it just seems like everything is
a scam everything is a rip-off
everything is a lie nothing is true yeah
you know and so the the carnival is like
a little petri dish of what happens when
you have a psychopathic business that
wants to run it this way
where everybody is being deceived
simultaneously
and it was a common element that
the carnivals would eventually get
exposed people would figure out what
they were doing and they would get run
out of town
and you know because the public would
realize that you know none of these none
of these games can be won they're just
taking our money well I'm excited of the
timeline for sure uh I'm gonna ask one
last question you've been so generous
with your time and your stories and your
honesty you said to ask about Saint
Germain is there a story about Saint
Germain oh wow yeah that's a good one
so in the 1700s there was a human being
who showed up and he seemed to have
never aged you might meet him in 1730
and you might meet him again in 1770.
and he looks exactly the same
uh he met directly with Benjamin
Franklin George Washington we know for a
fact he met with Franklin
and Saint Germain also met with Voltaire
the legendary inventor
Voltaire wrote a letter on his Deathbed
where he where he said to Saint Germain
maybe someday you will visit me again in
your marvelous flying machine
and then Voltaire wrote a book called
micro magos
which is the first ever science fiction
story in human history that was ever
written
micro magos was the title about
extraterrestrials who come to the Earth
and orbit the planet to see if there's
intelligent life here and in the
illustration that Voltaire commissioned
for this book in 1787
the craft that the beings fly here in in
micro magos is a flying saucer
so there's a 1700s illustration of the
same Flying Saucer that we're seeing in
the world today yeah
so it appears that Saint Germain uh he
could write with both hands he could
write a poem in one hand in a legal
document the other hand at the same time
he was a composer he played piano he
played violin as well as Paganini
apparently
he could take multiple small diamonds
put him in his hand hold his hand like
this and turn him into one large Diamond
he could take a silver coin and turn
into a gold coin he's an alchemist
and best of all it appears that he was
in cahoots with Benjamin Franklin
and that he was there on July 4 1776 in
the room
and gave a speech that led to the
signing of the Declaration of
Independence led to them giving up their
fear
and finally in 1840 some Masonic
organization found the secret transcript
of the speech
and so in book four I have Saint
germain's speech that he gave right
before they signed the Declaration of
Defense the real one and that's amazing
too because he's got coveted prophecies
in it yeah at one point in Saint
germain's speech which led to them
signing the Declaration of Independence
he says he says old man now bear your
arm
and it's exactly like somebody getting a
vaccination
so there's some very very interesting
stuff there so if anybody in your
audience wants to read these books
there's so much more we're only
scratching the surface uh it's at
thedisclosure.com
so that's the website we did an event
before called the disclosure was video
event we are going to do an event around
Michael prophecies as well I don't know
when this is going on I mean
hopefully soon but you know once we get
it out there I'm gonna have a video
course with Michael Broski as well we
don't have it yet but right now I'm
doing a very very good deal on the books
where you get it at a very low price and
again any one of them you can pick and
start with the one I probably love the
most right now is book four
because I've gone through ETS in the
Bible
there's so many quotes in the Bible that
reference flying saucers I go through
the whole thing with ezekiel's wheel
lots of stuff about UFO contact and
different cultures it's just an amazing
ride and it also really helped me get
back on my feet after two years of being
out of the circuit like this yeah wow
well you've been hard at work on
bringing us more truth that'll the truth
will set you free as they say so thank
you thank you so so much like I've been
so excited to talk to you for so many
years and the fact that I'm the first
one you've talked to in a couple of
years is just honestly such an honor and
grateful for your work and your
dedication and I'm so glad that you have
some identification of like all of the
things that you've been pushing so hard
for with UFOs and extraterrestrials and
the fact that it's
you know you you know you've been you've
been working so hard and sacrificing
your own time and life really for this
truth I'm glad that you can say I told
you so
well thank you Danica and I I just want
to thank you for how much your versed in
the subject material honestly
it was a really great interview because
of the depth of your passion for the
subject go get the books and we'll wait
for that flying crap I'll drive I'm can
I call it a driver or am I a pilot I
don't know for the yeah I was thinking
of that you know we uh
once we have I mean we're supposed to be
one year away from working hover car
prototypes and and you know I want you
to see that I want you to see that hover
car ride oh my God I want to see that I
want to perhaps see if I can learn how
to drive that
yeah I mean that's what we're going to
be doing you know this is going to
change the whole world we have a way to
mass produce hover cars we're going to
3D print the bodies out of volcanic
basalt material they're going to be
affordably priced you know maybe 30 000
so it's gonna we're gonna try to make it
so that people will be able to get a car
you know and president Trump came out
with agenda 47
where he took the stuff that I'm doing
with savati Aerospace and he made it
like they're creating 10 new cities in
America they're going to build power
plants hover cars all this stuff that I
was talking about is going to be done on
a much larger level the creation of new
cities and so like yeah I'm very very
excited I mean Michael is telling us
that within two years we're going to
have this Consciousness activation
that changes the way that our minds and
bodies function on the most basic level
we're going to be more telepathic it's
like everybody becomes a shaman hey man
we're all going to get this whether we
know it or not in within two years ah
foreign
thank you very much very excited thank
you Danica go feed the animals now it's
time to go feed the animals yes
and thank you for being pretty intense
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button